[Musique]
le parti socialiste qui prépare son
congrès des 7 et 8 avril prochain ce
sera aubervilliers le 78e congrès d'ici
là il y aura des élections internes
renouvellement des instances dirigeantes
au plan national également clan des
fédérations dont celle de martinique
bonjour frédéric bhérer bonjour mousse
viol tombe on joue aux auditrices et
auditeurs premier secrétaire de la
section de martinique de la fédération
socialiste de martinique et demain
demain frédéric bhérer il y aura un
débat télévisé est également radio chez
nos confrères privé du privé rtl et lci
entre les quatre candidats déclarés au
poste de premier secrétaire national
on va rappeler rapidement leur leur nom
luc carvounas stéphane le foll olivier
faure ainsi qu emmanuel mouret
frédérique béret les socialistes sont
ils un vrai tournant de leur histoire on
va faire court connaître ou disparaître
je préfère que vous fassiez disparaître
justement le terme de disparaître le
verbe dispute on peut faire que vous
parliez de refondation même pas honnête
puisque nous n'étions pas morts nous ne
sommes pas morts fondation ça dépend de
quel côté osé mais lorsqu'on regarde par
exemple les et les résultats des
élections et ce qui s'est passé ensuite
cela non mais vous regardez des
élections monsieur viol quand j'ai eu à
vous le dis ici déjà un parti politique
il va à des élections ils gagnent où il
perdrait il propose des orientations il
propose un projet et les électeurs
choisissent ou pas ça ne veut pas dire
que parce que les électeurs ne vous ont
pas choisi par rapport au contexte du
moment notamment que vous et moi pas du
tout et souvent vous êtes très fort
quand vous êtes dans l'opposition
et oui aujourd'hui le parti socialiste
c'est un parti très fort en tout cas
nous faisons un travail oppose
on a plutôt l'impression que la
république en marche continue son boulot
de rouleau compresseur qui aspirent tous
de partout que ce soit à droite que ce
soit la gauche que ce soit chez vous
même chez nous à vous avez vu que le
mais dieu du lorrain justin pamphile a
rallié en marche
enfin rallye vous vivre suffisamment
longtemps je l'espère ont constaté que
ce mouvement de la république en marche
justement est un mouvement cyclique
je vous le souhaite de vivre
suffisamment longtemps pour le voir et
vous n'aurez pas vivre si longtemps que
ça maintenant vous me parlez de monsieur
justin pas filmé en vidéo sa part afin -
ça c'est sa famille c'est pas filmer en
tant que responsable politique encore je
le suis encore frais puisque le congo
n'a pas eu lieu
j'ai le devoir d'avoir un regard quand
même c'est ce qui se passe notamment de
l'actualité politique et j'ai le devoir
d'analyser de mener des réflexions et de
décortiquer un peu les stratégies des
stratégies de qui de quoi de vous des
autres
juste deux fils par exemple ce que vous
me parliez 2 justin pamphile poker pour
continuer ce simple sans être trop long
parce que ma douce a pas un peu moins
mais justin pamphile
il a peut-être compris maintenant ou
alors il avait compris depuis longtemps
et ils hésitaient l'a compris quoi que
vous m'avez dit que il est sorti dans
son plan annoncé il annoncé chez le
gouverneur c'est y qui doit il est sorti
dans son coude martinique nouvelle et
alain public en mars il avait déjà chez
les investitures de marché dans un parti
politique ça veut dire qu'il a quitté un
parti politique qui arrivent dans nos
partis politiques en fait eu frédéric
bhérer vous voulez régler vos comptes
parce que vous aviez critiqué lorsque la
fsm avait décidé de se retirer de la
coalition sans primes géré règle aucun
compte puisque j'avais dit que le temps
ferait pour moi et pour qu'on puisse
comprendre la décision de la fédération
socialiste mais on avait eu 2 qui
permettront que les gens comprennent un
peu et je termine sur ce que vous disais
si les sorties de la poêle et dans un
parti politique c'est qu'il était dans
un parti politique ou alors il était
dans un ensemble qui fonctionnait comme
un parti politique mais vous comprenez
bien ce qu'on veut
les autres il a certainement compris que
ça ne marchait pas comme ça c'est vrai
l'élection du premier secrétaire se
déroulera les 29 et 30 mars premier
secrétaire des socialistes avec des
nouveautés on ne part plus de motion
mais de texte d'orientation ça change
quoi exactement
oui par exemple il y à un fait que nous
avons dû subir pendant des années des
décennies c'est le fait que on retrouve
à la direction du parti des personnes
qui sont en opposition avec la le chef
du parti et qui surtout fonctionne à
tout fonctionnait jusque là pratiquement
comme des opposants du fait qu' ils
avaient été élus choisis sur la base de
motion mais ce que certains ont toujours
appelé une espèce de synthèse et ont
regroupé tout le monde ce n'est pas la
meilleure manière pour gouverner par
conséquent on a trouvé cette solution de
délire nous responsables sur la base de
textes d'orientation au moins vous savez
exactement quelles sont les orientations
que veulent point les uns les autres et
dans le même temps
dans le même temps il y aura ces
élections au niveau des responsables de
fédérations locales
ça change quoi c'est la notion de motion
émanant de candidats nationale n'aura
vraiment plus d'impact sur les
fédérations plus local pas parce que
c'est les fédérations que sur le
national le conseil lui-même nationale
mais la question de savoir qu'il lui
aura des élections en même temps dans
les fédérations
ça n'a pas changé un seul a ajouté le
cas donc ça se fait un commentaire
et bien
je veux quoi que celui qui sera élu à la
tête de la fédération sans guillaume de
la martinique aux oies les coudées
franches aux a quand même des camarades
qui vont l'entourer au sein du conseil
fédéral qui ont dans sa direction dans
la même direction que lui en tout cas
et pour faire avancer les choses lui ou
elle lui ou elle bien sûr et ce tant à
oui biensur puisque les la campagne
officielle va commencer la semaine
prochaine le dépôt des candidatures se
fera dans ce sera à peu près judo
vendredi de la semaine prochaine
il y as qui comme candidat déclare ici
au poste de premier fédéral au moment
nous parlons
pour l'instant je n'ai reçu qu'une
lettre de candidature qui n'est pas
complète je le lui ai bien aux camarades
pourquoi elle n'est pas complet pourtant
ce matin deux jeunes lors d'un des
jeunes holden paris ternes être candidat
parce que il n'a pas il n'a pas fait
mention du texte d'orientation qui le
soutient ouais il faut le faire oui
c'est qui ce sera le seul candidat
je ne sais la seule candidate les
candidats notre droit des candidates
femmes
oui les candidatures ne sont pas bouclés
mais nous sommes un parti quand même
penser que vous êtes le patron de la
fédération vous sentez les choses vont y
venir les choses vous dire le compte que
ce serait vraiment vous faire injure
quand on est à ce poste
on doit savoir un peu ce qui se
passerait il y à des camarades qui passe
ouais faire acte de candidature
ils sont véritables on me sens pas un
véritable enthousiasme autour de ce
renouvellement puisque on le rappelle
frédéric bhérer vous ne serez pas
candidat à votre succession
ça nous chante pas d'être premier
fédéral de martinique au sein des
troupes socialistes
je peux vous dire que c'est un véritable
travail
il ya du boulot là dedans oui il faut
avoir un coeur bien accroché il faut
pouvoir entendre tout le monde
écouter tout le monde et partir à la
conquête des 130 encartés socialiste
aujourd'hui habilités à voter 130
centres seulement milite à voter
le siège social de 51 vols d'essai pas y
aurait voté oui habile et à rejeter
autres et ne lui dernièrement qui me
disait qu'il était socialiste de coeur
vous savez elle est conseillère
territoriale madame tel de trinity même
et cela parce que tout le monde n'en
socialiste de coeur mais yo pa ka vini
evry avait justement la sécurité le par
il n'y a pas de bilan à tirer de tout
cela pourquoi l'associé de la fédération
socialiste de martinique n'arrive pas à
séduire pourquoi ils n'arrivent pas à
grossir pourquoi ils n'arrivent pas à
établir un véritable plan de
communication évidemment de la
fédération puisque c'est le représentant
de la fédération qu'ils en fassent de
même et vous diluez votive et moi même
chose de mangroves au pardon de oui tout
à fait mais vous êtes dans votre choix
mais une manière de vous dire que ce qui
se passe là que vous décrivez
actuellement c'est ce qui se passe dans
tous les partis politiques et aussi dans
le monde associatif syndical
je voulais dit à maintes reprises déjà
bon quand je dis ça je ne m'appuie
passer ça pour dire qu'on fait rien pour
changer les choses en oeuvre pour
changer les choses
et justement vous avez fait allusion
tout à l'heure à manon représentation
pour ce poste ce n'est pas que je me
défile j'aurais même souhaité continuer
par rapport au contexte du moment
cependant lorsque j'ai pris la tête de
la fédération j'ai été clair j'avais dit
que je faisais un mandat et que je passe
la main
oui j'en ai fait deux mêmes 2 me ça fait
plus de cinq ans que je suis à la tête
de la fédération
je pense j'ai fait du boulot je n'ai pas
tout réussi avec mes camarades et je
pense que il faut passer la main pour
permettre à d'autres forces vives
d'apporter l'eau si je garde une autre
chose à faire lorsqu'on est à la tête de
la fédération socialiste de martinique
ici au plan local
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup parce que on
a beaucoup camarades qu'il faut essayer
de ramener à la maison
duval il faut aller conquérir attendait
beaucoup moins c'est le nombre de fois
que nous nous maintenons toutes les
trois en uni à faire venir nous piquer
sur les personnalités les plus
emblématiques qui font des fois cette
maison socialiste au coin bleu matic
tous les militants tous les camarades
sont des camarades emblématique
il nous reste 30 mais vraiment 10
secondes votre soutenez qui parmi les
quatre candidats
oui merci pour cette question parce que
j'allais au maître deleu vous en parler
une résistance j'y suis le mandataire de
le cameroun s merci d'avoir été ce matin
avec nos frédéric bhérer on rappelle que
vous êtes encore pour quelques jours
secrétaire un premier secrétaire de la
fédération socialiste de martinique
bonne journée bonjour n'aime ce volcan
je vous remercie
merci aux auditeurs
[Musique]